got they were Lively unfortunately is
the all good news back at the kitchen
there's been a serious incident all
right guys let's go tea
Lawrence I need you for two minutes
please seriously guys this is where I
think that I've been let down today
because I've just been told that we've
found this in the dressing room and
someone's been nicking onions chilies
and garlic guys no really
yeah it makes me feel stupid we cannot
steal from the kitchen anyone who sees
belong to who else we cannot take
anything out of the kitchen next week
you'll be a knife no Chuck we stop now I
decide to be a verb in the other side
where I look at me see I think cooking
cooking myself that gets me into serious
[ __ ] so look I'm a freak but you're
letting me down
what do you let your team down I was
dealt with yeah let's move on I wasn't
thinking I just thought there was
extreme yeah well I don't want to do now
is falling out and argue each other
that's the problem they get one little
issue and it becomes massive and they
flip what a [ __ ] joke
don't say to me Nakia it's all said and
done once the rowing starts no one banks
down this lock will argue about anything
Oh guys guys let's finish on the hide
let's not waste 10 hours of grass I
can't believe after all their great
teamwork and success my brigades falling
apart in front of my eyes there was some
good workers there today I mean some
really good workers and the ones I
thought weren't gonna
work and stay focused did
y'all never about in many ways because I
could I can be six short
within a 30 second argument and that's
that's the knife-edge my biggest
problems gonna be keeping the team
together that's what I that's why I've
got my work cut out because there's so
many
feisty insecure characters that is
almost built on a stack of cards
[Music]